So, we just saw what an outsourcing
conversation might look
like when it includes the entrepreneur,
a designer, and a developer.
I want to pull out a couple of parts of
that conversation for us to focus on.
The first is a tendency
towards scope creep.
Scope creep is whenever
the first version of your app
isn't the minimum viable product.
Scope creep is bad.
It gets in the way of launching and
iterating, which means that you're
spending a lot more time building
things than building the right things.
As an entrepreneur,
you have to make sure that your
team isn't introducing scope creep.
But you also have to make sure that
you aren't introducing scope creep.
Scope creep affects both time and
budget.
In the consultation we just saw,
Carl did a very good job of
managing the scope creep.
And he was the one who suggested
that we pare down our V1 of the app.
In real life, that job will fall on you.
This idea of scope creep is especially
noticeable in the poll between
the developer and the designer,
James wanted to spend some time at first
working on the overview page,
making it gorgeous.
Carl noted that was actually a waste of
time for this minimum viable product.
Another tension you may experience, is a
designer wanting to build things custom
without thinking about how long it
will actually take to build them.
As an entrepreneur,
you need to be balancing budget with
the time spent by your contractors.
A good rule of thumb is to
launch your minimum viable
product without anything custom or
fancy if you can avoid it.
Once your app has started
getting feedback from customers,
you can make it as fancy and
beautiful as your designer wants.
Until then,
stick to the default components.